what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video there are a few more
details coming out about the final
season a game of Thrones but before we
get started I just want to give a quick
reminder to those of you that are
interested in the giveaway that I'm
doing I will announce what the prizes
are and how you can enter at the end of
this video so if you're interested in
participating in the giveaway make sure
you stay until the very end now let's
dig into the video today's story is
compliments of Watchers on the wall
which is my favorite website and Twitter
page to follow for all the leading news
surrounding any and everything Game of
Thrones related the first thing I want
to talk about is the ending of Game of
Thrones because I thought this news was
pretty interesting although I am not
100% buying it most of you should know
by now that the entire plot for Game of
Thrones season 7 was leaked online all
the way back in October this was
something I reported on as soon as it
came out in October before season 7
really even began filming and this leak
was damn near 100% accurate from some of
the dialogue all the way up to the major
scenes was leaked months before season 7
was set to premiere and now that season
8 is beginning their pre-production
leaks are already starting to come out
about season 8 which is something that
HBO wants to definitely avoid it would
really suck to have an entire season
leaked but to have the ending leaked of
the most successful show in history
would be tragic so according to some of
the people at HBO they're gonna take
some drastic measures to try and prevent
this from happening once again I know
there are already some season 8 leaks
circulating the internet but I think
it's pretty obvious that those leaks are
100% fake I only read the leak for
episode 1 of season 8 and that was all I
needed to see to know that it was fake
in my opinion there were so many
inconsistencies in that leak even for
Dan and Dave standards so for all of you
that keep asking me about the season 8
leaks that is my answer
they are fake there is a reason why I
never made breakdown videos on those
leaks like I did for season 7 because I
knew right away that they were trash but
anyways HBO's programming president
Casey boys was recently at Bethlehem
college and he was discussing the Game
of Thrones finale for season 8 he was
talking about how challenging it can be
when trying to write a great ending for
a TV show especially one that is as
popular as Game of Thrones but
exactly what he said I know in Game of
Thrones the ending they're gonna shoot
multiple versions that nobody really
knows what happens boy says you have to
do that on a long show because when
you're shooting something people know so
they are going to shoot multiple
versions so that there's no real
definitive answer until the end
basically what he's saying is he knows
there's gonna be a ton of leaks again
because at this point it's pretty much
unavoidable unless you keep all of the
creators locked in a room and you shoot
every scene indoors that way no one can
take any photos of the actors on set
it's going to be impossible for Game of
Thrones to hide everything that they are
doing because this show is a global
success with rabid fans hiding around
every corner with a camera and drones
and microscopes trying to dissect
everything they are doing and I will be
the first to admit I'm definitely one of
those people I wish I live near the sets
and locations because that would be
there several times a week trying to get
the scoop on what's going on but
according to Casey from HBO he said
they're gonna film multiple endings that
way when they get leaked again none of
us are gonna know which one is the real
thing but HBO has said things like this
before and guess what they never
actually did it and everything was still
leaked and we all knew exactly what was
going to happen and I would guarantee
it's gonna happen again with season 8
this show is just too popular and
everyone on set knows this too and there
is always gonna be that one personal and
said that can't keep their mouths shut
and things will get leaked again things
that are even done behind closed doors I
think it's inevitable at this point Kit
Harington was on Jimmy Kimmel and he
said they were filming fake scenes
during the making a season seven but
even if that was true it didn't matter
because we all still knew exactly what
was going to happen because the entire
plot was leaked before they even started
filming anything outside I also have to
give credit to the person that wrote
this short article about their story
from Watchers on the wall because they
make a great point right here they said
HBO doesn't have the budget to film
multiple finales that will never air
Game of Thrones has the biggest budget
in television history and they still
stretch it out to the max and are never
able to include everything that they
would like to so they can't really
afford to make several fake endings it
would be a waste of time and money they
might have two actors standing next to
each other one said that won't actually
film scenes together but I doubt they're
gonna be able to fake any of the ending
scenes especially if the ending involves
any kind of a battle
they are already expensive enough and
extremely hard to coordinate and I think
they would never be able to pull off a
few fake ones just to fool some sneaky
fans who may be nearby what telephoto
lenses snapping pictures I think it
would be interesting if they did film a
few different endings though because
that way they could pick the best one
and use it and I'm praying that george
RR martin helps them with the ending
because i would be so disappointed if
they screwed it up i think a bad ending
can hurt the legacy of the entire show
because fans are already pissed about
the way the last few seasons played out
so I can only imagine the hate this show
would get if they botched this ending in
my opinion if I could pick the ultimate
ending I would want george RR martin to
write the ending and I would want Miguel
supports Nick to direct the ending
george RR martin is obviously the
greatest writer this show has ever had
considering this story as his baby his
creation and I think Miguel supports
Nick is the greatest director this show
has ever had he filmed episodes like
hardhome and battle of the bastards and
winds of winter I think those two
together could knock it out of the park
but that's just my opinion
let me ask everybody this what is your
thoughts on them filming multiple
endings to throw off the fans do you
think they will actually do something
like that or not and do you think it's
actually a good idea it sounds like a
waste of time and money to me I think
they need to focus on getting things
right and not trying to worry about
spoilers because it's gonna happen
regardless if you ask me before I get
into any of the details about the
giveaway there is one more update
regarding season 8 and this is pretty
interesting too that can lend itself to
much speculation casting calls have
started and as of right now they are
looking for two new actors for scenes
that are taking place in the last season
obviously they're looking for child
actors for both of these new roles and
the first one they need is for someone
to portray a northern girl the character
should be around the age of 8 years old
but they will hire anyone up to the age
of 10 they describe this role as a
straight-talking northern accented girl
someone remarkable for her dauntless
Ness and integrity it says this
character was brought up in a family of
soldiers and shares their fearlessness
this role was said to be a very nice
standout part for a strong-minded young
girl with a fighting spirit this role
will need to be filled by mid no
member because that's around the time
that they plan on starting to film her
scenes this character definitely sounds
like a Lyanna Mormont or arias start
kind of roll and now I'm very curious to
see who this person may be especially
which family she is actually from I find
this very interesting that this new
character will have a standout role in
the last season who do you think it
could possibly be they're also searching
for a young boy around the age of 8 to
12 years old and this character needs to
be physically fit with an agile look
someone with a good distinctive face
this role is described as being from a
poor background someone who has to fight
to make his way into the world this
character needs to be able to completely
own this scenes that he is in and it
sounds like they will be using him for
multiple scenes which is interesting as
well I wasn't really expecting them to
be introducing too many new characters
in this last season but this sounds like
two decent roles that could have some
significance I'm sure some photos will
start coming out as they are filming
scenes and we should get some more
answers once we see what these kids
actually look like and the type of
clothes that they're wearing I am kind
of anxious to learn about these two new
roles so leave all your comments down
below because I'm curious to know what
some of you think about these new
updates but now let's get into the fun
stuff if you want to participate in this
new giveaway the link will be down in
the description and the link will be
pinned at the top of the comments all
you need to do is follow that link and
follow those steps because there will be
multiple ways you can enter through that
link which will give you more chances of
winning and I will be giving away
multiple prizes to more than just one
person completely selected at random the
first prize will be the complete a Song
of Ice and Fire series today and some of
you might have not read the books yet so
this is gonna be your chance to win all
of the books that are out thus far the
second prize will be the world of Ice
and Fire novel which is a great addition
to anyone's collection in my opinion I
have a copy of this myself
and I gave away a copy of this already
in one of my previous giveaways and the
third and final prize will be the Game
of Thrones Monopoly game I don't know
about you but I have always loved
playing Monopoly so I don't think you
can go wrong with a game of Thrones
edition of this game and like I said
there's three different prizes so there
will be three different winners selected
randomly the first name that gets picked
will get to choose whatever prize they
want between these three the second
person that you
picked will get to choose whatever they
want between the two remaining gifts and
the third person who gets picked will
obviously get whatever prize was not
picked I think these are three good
choices either way so hopefully all of
you will participate the link will be
down in the description or the comments
if you want to play and if you subscribe
to this channel you will automatically
get two entries into the drawing which
will give you better odds of winning one
of these prizes I will announce the
winners within the next 30 days and I'm
gonna randomly announce the winners in
the video so if you are participating
make sure you watch although the videos
that I release within the next 30 days
so you can claim your prize because if I
don't hear back from you within 30 days
of me announcing your name then that's
your loss and I will take that prize and
place it in a new giveaway so make sure
you keep your eyes peeled if your name
is picked you can contact me here on
YouTube you can call man on the video
that I call your name in or you can send
me an email or you can even send me a
tweet on Twitter I want to thank
everybody for watching today's video I
truly appreciate all of you who stay and
watch it until the very end because that
really does help out the channel a lot I
also want to thank my patreon supporters
and I have to thank all of the new ones
who joined me on patreon this week thank
you very much for that and I hope you
all have a great day
I will see you in the next one bye
you